first of all Rand Paul shouldn't even be  on this stage he's number 11 he's got 1%  in the polls and how he got up here  there's far too many people anyway do we  want some with that kind of character  that kind of careless language to be  negotiating with Putin we want someone  like that to be negotiating with Iran I  think really there's a sophomoric  quality that is entertaining about mr.  Trump but I am worried I'm very  concerned about him having him in charge  of the nuclear weapons because I think  his response his visceral response to  attack people on their appearance short  tall fat ugly my goodness that happened  in junior high  are we not way above that would we not  all be worried to have someone like that  in charge of the nuclear corset mr.  Koppel I never attacked him on his look  and believe me this plenty of subject  matter right there that I can tell you  Jake Jake I wonder if I want to give mr.  Truong